- Well recently, you,
you had a blessing to honor
the spirit of the sunny loss,
which I think is so beautiful.
- Thank you
- I know, I actually
know quite a few people
who have lost babies and
had miscarriages and it's one
of those things where half
the time, like half the time,
I feel like those friends never
want to talk about it again.
- Yes.
- And then the other
half it's like therapy
for them to talk about it.
- Yeah
- It's therapy for them
to remember every year.
It's, it's so different.
- Yeah. We're very vocal about it
in the household because mainly
because my kids are, you
know, so much a part of it,
they are, they were part of the blessing.
Like, I mean, Miles really sat down
and paid attention and you know,
everyone wonders why, you know,
mommy's crying because of baby Jack.
And, you know, sometimes if I'm just sad
at just having like a sad night or
a little bit of a down night,
they look at me and they want
to talk about baby Jack and
they want to talk about,
they'll bring, you know,
the little box over or the
flowers or, or, you know,
we, it's, we're just
very vocal about it and
how he's, you know, he's everywhere.
He's in the air, he's in the sky.
He's, he's surrounds us every day.
And I kind of always been like
that, with death and loss,
but yeah, my thing was,
it took me so long to,
you know,
kind of close the chapter on it.
Of course you never, it's
never like full closure,
but like, I, it happened.
And then I threw myself into this book and
I threw myself into writing and, and.
- For a bit of distraction, you think?
- Yeah, definitely.
I mean, that became like,
it became its own thing of,
and then I looked back one
day and I was like, oh,
like I just stopped myself.
And I was like, oh, I'm
still really sad about this.
Like it's, I'm like,
- I think that it is incredible
that you are doing that
though, because I think a lot
of people feel bad about that.
About still holding and it's
like, that's a horrible loss.
- Yeah
- That's a huge loss.
- And I am opposite of
you. I do not like to talk
about death.
Like, I am like shut down central.
So I think it's an amazing,
I wish I were more like you with that.
I wish I were more open, like,
cause I think that a lot of people,
that's how they find healing
- Yes
- And how a lot of people never heal from.
- Yeah.
- Because you don't talk about it.
- Yeah, it helps a lot.
And I stuck it in the back of my mind.
And then, and then it, once yeah,
I realized that I remember
looking back and I called my OB
and I was like, I don't,
this it's been eight months.
And I don't even really
know what went wrong or what
happened or what to tell
people when we talk about it.
I didn't have any of the answers
for that because I had just
shut it off for so long.
So really going through everything and,
and finding peace with it was,
was so big and finding
peace with my entire life.
Like it was such a big, you know,
it was such a big like
sigh, like breath of release
relief and it just felt,
so it felt so nice the other
day to have the monks there.
And, and
- That's cool.
- That was great.
- I think it's really
good for your kids too.
I don't know if your kids are
already talking about death,
but my daughter is obsessed
with it and she definitely
doesn't want me to die.
Every night she tells me.
- Yeah. I get it.
- But I think it's a hard conversation.
- They do get in that age, right?
- It's a hard conversation to have.
So I think what you
are doing is beautiful.
What y'all are doing,
cause it's a beautiful
way to remind your kids.
Like this is life.
- Yes
- Like sometimes death occurs.
Like it's inevitable, for all of us.
- My kids are all about like, talk,
they think I'm going to die all the time
cause of the Disney movies.
So they just.
- I know
- Oh my God. And like, anytime
my daughter tells a story,
everyone dies that could
possibly take care of her.
And I'm like, where is she learning this?
And I'm like, oh from all
the movies she watches.
- Oh, the stuff I show
her. Oh, yeah that's it.
- All those Disney
films are supposed to be
like really happy, but it, you should be,
I guess, teaching them, you
know death at some point?
- Yeah. I know.
Oh, they're prepped for it.
Thanks Disney.
(laughter)
- So, wait.
So you spoke about, you
said you weren't drinking.
Right? So congrats.
I didn't know that actually.
- No, I feel great.
- Its been months, right?
- Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- I know.
- Do you feel like it? I
feel like I don't drink it.
I know people laugh because
I'll joke about drink.
I actually don't drink much
unless I'm really here.
And, and I, I joke about it, but I'm,
I'm not really heavy drinker.
Cause I feel like I'm not a good drinker.
I am not.
- Oh, I appreciate people
that can like do it
and enjoy the taste and
the feeling. John drinks.
I mean, John would have
a glass of wine at the
end of the night or like a whiskey,
like slow watching a good show.
And it's like, you know, it's amazing.
- What an old man. That's great.
- He really is. He really, really is.
- With a cigar.
- It's so nice to see
someone that enjoys it
because I look at me and
I'm just like, cause I
was teetering for a while.
I was like, am I never
going to drink again?
Am I really never going to
have a glass of wine again, a
glass of champagne to celebrate something?
And then I'm like, no,
there's like so much pressure
in thinking that way.
But also like it's not for my
body and I wasn't drinking for
any reason other than
to like heal things and
- Escape
- Yeah, an escape, so.
- So I think that's me too.
That's why I don't like drinking.
- Yeah, It's not for me.
- Every once in a while. Yeah.
I'm like one of those
people, I'm not like hardcore
about anything.
I, once you say never, that's
the time when you do it.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Trust me.
- But I do think that growing up,
I have learned about my body
and how I react to certain
things. And man, mama is
one drink in and that's it.
- Yeah, no.
- It's depends on the situation.
- I know it's funny a lot more people like
if you like really get in tune
with your body and realize
like, if it's your thing or not,
I think it would save a lot of
people because it just really
isn't.
But, we have such a culture.
- It's such a social thing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, and then I read
this book about, you know,
like the pressure that
people put on mothers that
to drink and how casual it is for like,
to like really escape,
like motherhood and stuff.
- Yeah
- And, and how normalized that is.
And I was just like, I don't
want to be one of those people.
And now I have all this new
energy for my kids and it's
just, yeah.
- Yeah
- This whole year, it's
just been like incredible
for being able to be a better
wife, a better mother, a better friend.
Yeah. It just, it just
feels really good now.